even heart ended up in a wheelchair
yesterday after a friendly foot race
with former NFL player Stephen Ridley
took a dark turn here's what happened
Kevin and Steven were at a party
enjoying themselves when a debate
started about who was faster between the
two as a former professional athlete
Steven Ridley was obviously pretty
confident that he could beat Kevin Hart
in a foot race but Kevin seemed equally
assure of himself and did not back down
the two ended up going outside to settle
the debate in the street but
unfortunately for Kevin his hips and
abdomen will never be the same I'm in a
wheelchair why well because I tried to
jump out there and do some young stuff
Kevin Hart is in tremendous shape and
the race actually looked closer than
anyone would have probably expected but
dude it's still an NFL player these guys
might as well be another species of
human being Stephen Ridley ran a 4-6
40-yard dash when he was in the league
which is the equivalent of almost 18
miles per hour on a 225 pound frame